JF : Nous perdons du temps.
Nous avons un temps limité.
LT : Juste d'être avec elle me vide complètement.
(Rires)
JF : Vous n'avez encore rien vu.
Bref, désolée.
PM : Dites-moi, que recherchez-vous chez une amie ?
LT : Qu'elle sache s'amuser,
qu'elle ait de l'audace,
qu'elle soit communicative, qu'elle ait des idées,
qu'elle soit même un tout petit peu passionnée par notre planète,
qu'elle soit décente, qu'elle soit juste
et qu'elle pense que j'en vaux la peine.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
JF : Ce matin, je réfléchissais.
Je ne sais pas ce que je ferais sans mes amies.
En fait, c'est : « J'ai mes amies, donc je suis. »
LT : (Rires)
JF : Non, c'est vrai.
J'existe parce que mes amies sont là.
Tu es l'une d'entre elles.
Je ne sais pas pour toi, mais...
(Rires)
Elles me rendent plus forte, plus intelligente,
plus courageuse.
Elles me tapotent sur l'épaule pour me remettre dans le droit chemin.
Et la plupart sont beaucoup plus jeunes que moi.
Tu comprends ? C'est sympa... LT : Merci.
(Rires)
JF : C'est vrai. Tu en fais partie car... c'est sympa
d'avoir encore quelqu'un avec qui jouer, de qui apprendre
quand on s'approche de la fin.
Je m'en approche... J'y serai avant toi.
LT : Je suis contente de te voir vieillir à côté de moi.
(Rires)
JF : Je te montre la voie.
LT : Ça a toujours été le cas.
PM : En vieillissant,
et alors que nous vivons des expériences différentes
que faites-vous pour maintenir cette amitié ?
LT : Il vous faut beaucoup de...
JF : Je peux vous dire qu'elle ne m'invite pas souvent.
LT : J'utilise beaucoup les média sociaux --
Tais-toi, c'est bon --
(Rires)
LT : Je surveille mes mails et mes SMS
pour voir mes amies
et leur répondre aussi vite que possible,
car je sais qu'elles ont besoin de mes conseils,
(Rires)
de mon soutien.
car nombre de mes amies sont écrivains, activistes ou actrices,
toi, tu es les trois.
Et beaucoup d'autres choses.
Et je veux te répondre le plus vite possible,
je veux que tu saches que je suis là pour toi.
JF : Tu utilises des émoticônes ?
LT : Euh... JF : Non ?
LT : C'est gênant. JF : J'adore les émoticônes..
LT : J'écris..
Je mets en mots mon bonheur, mes félicitations
et ma tristesse.
JF : Tu écris tout...
LT : J'écris, chaque lettre.
(Rires)
JF : Quelle puriste.
Tu sais, en vieillissant,
je comprends mieux l'importance de l'amitié
et je fais des efforts pour
établir le contact, voir les personnes, ne pas laisser passer le temps.
Je lis beaucoup,
comme Lily le sait,
j'envoie les livres que j'aime à mes amies.
LT : Sachant que nous viendrions ici,
tu m'as envoyé nombre de livres sur les femmes, l'amitié féminine,
et j'ai été surprise par le nombre de livres,
d'études récentes sur le sujet...
JF : Et tu en étais contente ? LT : Oui.
(Rires)
PM : Et...
LT : C'est très important parce que c'est un autre exemple
de la façon dont les femmes sont mises à part, de côté, marginalisées.
Il y a eu très peu d'études réalisées à notre sujet,
même si nous nous sommes souvent portées volontaires.
JF : C'est sûr.
(Rires)
LT : C'est très excitant et cela va tous vous intéresser.
Une étude de la Harvard Medical School a montré
que les femmes qui entretiennent une amitié solide avec une femme
sont moins sujettes aux problèmes de santé,
aux handicaps physiques, en vieillissant,
et elles ont plus de chances de mener une vie bien plus tonique, palpitante...
JF : Et plus longue...
LT : Et heureuse.
JF : On vit 5 ans de plus que les hommes.
LT : J'échangerais ces années contre du bonheur.
(Rires)
LT : Le plus important c'est que --
les résultats étaient si excitants et concluants --
les chercheurs ont trouvé
que ne pas avoir d'amies proches est aussi nuisible à votre santé,
que fumer ou être en surpoids.
JF : Il y a autre chose --
LT : Moi j'ai terminé...
(Rires)
JF : Alors écoute-moi, parce que cela va encore plus loin.
Pendant des années, des dizaines d'années,
les recherches sur le stress ne concernaient que les hommes.
Ce n'est que récemment, que l'on s'est intéressé au stress chez les femmes,
et il s'avère que lorsque nous, les femmes, quand nous sommes stressées,
l'oxytocine se répand dans notre corps.
C'est l'hormone du bien-être, qui calme et limite le stress.
La compagnie de nos amies en augmente la concentration.
C'est sûrement une des raisons pour lesquelles nous vivons plus longtemps.
Dommage pour les hommes, ils n'ont pas cela.
Chez les hommes, la testostérone diminue les effets de l'oxytocine.
LT : Quand toi, moi et Dolly travaillions de 9h à 17h...
JF : Oh...
LT : On riait, on riait tellement.
nous avons tant en commun mais sommes si différentes.
Elle est comme les reines d'Hollywood,
moi comme une caïd de Detroit,
[Dolly] est une enfant du Sud, d'une ville pauvre du Tennessee,
et en tant que femmes nous avons tant en commun,
et certainement que --
on riait -- notre espérance de vie s'est certainement allongée de 10 ans.
JF : Nous avons beaucoup croisé nos jambes.
(Rires)
Si tu vois de quoi je parle.
LT : Je pense que nous voyons tous.
(Rires)
PM : Tu prolonges nos vies de décennies en ce moment.
Parmi les livres que Jane nous a envoyés sur l'amitié féminine,
il y en avait un d'une femme que nous admirons beaucoup :
Sœur Joan Chittister,
qui a dit, concernant l'amitié féminine,
que les amies, ce n'est pas qu'un lien social
mais un lien spirituel.
Pensez-vous à vos amies ainsi ?
Ajoutent-elles quelque chose de spirituel à vos vies ?
LT : Spirituel... Oui je le crois.
En particulier pour celles que je connais depuis longtemps,
avec qui j'ai passé du temps,
je vois en elles l'essence spirituelle,
la tendresse, la vulnérabilité.
Il y a de l'amour, un élément amoureux dans la relation.
Je vois au plus profond ton âme.
PM : Pensez-vous que, Jane...
LT : Mais j'ai des super-pouvoirs.
JF : Les amies sont différentes.
Il y a les amies au travail, en soirée,
j'en ai beaucoup de celles-là.
(Rires)
Mais celles qui génèrent l'oxytocine ont...
elles paraissent spirituelles car on ouvre son cœur, non ?
C'est profond.
Je verse de nombreuses larmes avec mes amies intimes.
Pas parce que je suis triste mais juste touchée et inspirée.
LT : L'une d'entre vous va bientôt partir.
(Rires)
PM : Nous sommes deux, Lily, de qui parles-tu ?
Quand les femmes parlent de leurs amitiés,
les hommes ont toujours l'air un peu perplexes.
A votre avis, quelles sont les différences
entre l'amitié masculine et l'amitié féminine ?
JF : Il y en a beaucoup,
et nous devrions avoir de l'empathie pour les hommes...
(Rires)
car ils n'ont pas ce que nous avons.
Et qui pourrait expliquer pourquoi ils meurent avant.
(Rires)
J'ai beaucoup de compassion pour les hommes
parce que les femmes, sans blaguer, nous...
les relations entre femmes, nos amitiés nous mettent à nu, sont profondes.
Elles nous révèlent.
Nous nous exposons -- les hommes ne font pas cela.
Combien de fois vous ai-je demandé : « Comment je m'en sors ? »,
« Ai-je foiré ? »
PM : Tu t'en sors très bien.
(Rires)
JF : Nous posons ce genre de questions
à nos amies
et les hommes non.
Les relations entre femmes sont dites de face à face,
alors que celles entre hommes sont de côte-à-côte.
LT : La plupart du temps, les hommes ne veulent pas révéler leurs émotions,
ils veulent les enterrer.
C'est la pensée générale et conventionnelle.
Ils préféreraient aller dans leurs cavernes d'hommes
et regarder un match, jouer au golf
ou parler de sport, de chasse, de voiture ou de sexe.
C'est un comportement plus masculin.
JF : Tu veux dire... LT : Ils parlent de sexe.
Ils ont peut-être des relations sexuelles
s'ils emmènent quelqu'un dans leurs cavernes...
(Rires)
JF : Une chose que je trouve très intéressante,
et inconnue des psychologues jusqu'à récemment,
est que les hommes naissent aussi relationnels que les femmes.
Si vous regardez des vidéos de nouveaux-nés garçons et filles,
vous verrez les garçons, comme les filles,
regarder les yeux de leur mère,
ayant besoin de cet échange relationnel d'énergie.
Quand la mère regarde ailleurs, on peut voir le désarroi de l'enfant,
même les garçons pleuraient.
Ils ont besoin de relations.
La question est pourquoi, en grandissant, cela change-t-il ?
La réponse est la culture patriarcale,
qui dit aux garçons et aux jeunes hommes
qu'avoir besoin d'une relation, d'être émotionnel avec quelqu'un est féminin.
Qu'un vrai homme ne demande pas d'explications et n'exprime pas de besoin,
ne va pas chez le médecin quand il est malade.
Ne demande pas d'aide.
Il y a une citation que j'aime :
« Les hommes craignent qu'en devenant nous, ils effacent le je. »
Sa notion de lui-même.
Alors que chez les femmes, la notion du soi-même a toujours été poreuse.
Mais notre « nous » est notre grâce salvatrice,
elle nous rend fortes.
Pas que nous soyons meilleures que les hommes,
nous n'avons simplement pas à prouver notre masculinité.
LT : Et...
JF : C'est une citation de Gloria Steinem.
Nous pouvons exprimer notre humanité... LT : Je connais Gloria Stenem.
JF : Je sais que tu sais qui c'est, mais je crois...
(Rires)
C'est une super citation.
Nous ne sommes pas meilleures que les hommes,
nous n'avons simplement pas à prouver notre masculinité.
C'est très important.
LT : On inculque trop aux hommes comment être à l'aise
dans la culture patriarcale.
Nous devons changer quelque chose.
JF : Les amitiés féminines sont une source d'énergie renouvelable.
LT : C'est ce qui est excitant à ce propos.
C'est parce que nos amitiés --
les amitiés féminines sont bonnes pour notre sororité,
et que la sororité peut être une force très puissante,
pour donner au monde --
pour en faire ce qu'il faut --
donner les choses dont les humains ont désespérément besoin.
PM : C'est pourquoi nous en parlons,
car les amitiés féminines sont,
comme tu l'as dit Jane,
une source d'énergie renouvelable.
Comment l'utiliser ?
JF : Démographiquement, ce sont les femmes qui augmentent le plus,
en particulier les femmes âgées.
Si nous exploitons notre pouvoir, nous pouvons changer le monde.
Et devine quoi ? Nous le devons.
(Applaudissements)
Et rapidement.
Une des choses que nous devons faire,
nous le pouvons en tant que femmes,
nous mettons en place les standards de la consommation.
Nous devons moins consommer.
Nous, dans le monde occidental, devons moins consommer
et, quand nous achetons, nous devons acheter des produits locaux,
quand nous achetons à manger, cela doit être produit localement.
Nous devons changer nos habitudes.
Nous devons devenir indépendants des énergies fossiles.
Et les entreprises d'énergies fossiles --
Exxon, Shell et tous ces méchants-là --
ils sont méchants --
vont nous dire que c'est impossible sans revenir à l'Âge de pierre,
que les alternatives ne sont pas totalement développées,
et ce n'est pas vrai.
Il y a actuellement des pays dans le monde
qui vivent majoritairement d'énergies renouvelables et s'en sortent bien.
Ils nous disent que si nous nous sevrons des énergies fossiles,
nous allons retourner à l'Âge de Pierre,
et que si nous commençons à utiliser des énergies renouvelables
et ne forons pas dans l'Arctique,
LT : Mon Dieu.
JF : dans les sables bitumineux d'Alberta --
Exactement.
Nous serons...
il y aura plus de démocratie, de travail et de bien-être,
et ce sont les femmes qui vont montrer la voie.
LT : Nous avons peut-être l'élan
pour lancer la troisième vague du mouvement féministe
avec notre sororité à travers le monde,
avec des femmes que nous ne voyons pas, ne rencontrerons peut-être jamais,
mais nous nous réunissons
parce que,
Aristote l'a dit,
la plupart des gens,
les gens mourraient sans amitié masculine.
Et le mot important ici est « masculine ».
Car ils pensaient que l'amitié devait être entre des gens égaux
et les femmes n'étaient pas l'égal...
JF : Ils pensaient que nous n'avions pas d'âmes, même les Grecs.
LT : Cela montre combien Aristote était limité.
(Rires)
Voici le meilleur.
Les hommes ont besoin des femmes maintenant.
La planète a besoin des femmes.
La constitution américaine a besoin des femmes.
Nous ne sommes même pas dans la constitution.
JF : Tu ne parles pas de l'Equal Rights Amendment.
LT : En effet.
Justice Ginsberdg a dit quelque chose comme :
chaque constitution écrite depuis la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
inclut une clause qui fait des femmes des citoyennes de statut égal,
mais pas la nôtre.
Il faudrait commencer par là.
Très, très léger...
JF : Exactement.
(Applaudissements)
L'égalité des genres est comme une vague,
elle soulèverait tous les bateaux, pas seulement les femmes.
PM : Nous avons besoin de nouveaux modèles pour montrer
comment être amies,
comment penser différemment à notre pouvoir,
en tant que consommatrices,
citoyennes du monde,
et cela fait de Jane et Lily
des modèles sur l'amitié féminine,
et ce depuis longtemps
même si elles ne sont pas toujours d'accord.
Merci.
Merci à vous deux.
(Applaudissements)
JF : Merci.
LT : Merci.
(Applaudissements)